all right speaking of madness that's
occurring on Capitol Hill I'm sure
you've seen the video by now if you
haven't we're gonna play the video on
the confrontation between Alex Jones and
Marco Rubio and what actually I'm not
gonna say anything let's watch the first
part of the video here go after freedom
democratic person conservative the the
not answering him just as Republicans
are acting like it isn't happening
thank God Trump is weird oh yeah that's
really where there's no purge of
conservatives well I think the bigger
bias is against freedom of expression
everybody should be there's a there's a
look I see more going on here but you
say I don't exist it's in a heckler I
depress the gaggle look at this guy he's
saying that I don't exist and they're
upside sure and they so much me and
these very hairy he plays dumb alright
so the first part of the I'm sorry I'm
sorry because the first thing that comes
to mind forget about the video the first
thing that comes to mind is this is a
monster of your own creation Marco Rubio
and now the monster of your own creation
and Marco Rubio obviously in my last
sentence is just proxy for conservatives
in general conservatives across the
nation have benefited from the insanity
and I don't use that in an ableist sense
I use that in this guy is intentionally
playing this role this role of madness
in order to capitalize on this madness
it's it's ridiculous what's going on but
conservatives benefited from this for
years they were able to keep them at bay
and get to get their votes and get their
support in media and and still be able
to keep them over there and finally Alex
Jones came to Capitol Hill and and
confronted Marco Rubio now this is not
to say I don't really care in this
argument in terms of who won who didn't
win when two monsters fight you sit back
and let them destroy each other
but I will have to say in regard to
Marco Rubio that Alex Jones did such a
great job of being a pretentious prick
that for a moment there you forget how
disgusting Marco Rubio is himself take a
look at this clip
well that's Facebook just what your
jeweler need to be regulated like what
do they need tens of billions of use
Infowars Rush Limbaugh he knows who in
Fort Worth is playing this joke over
here that's why the D platform didn't
work Mike thank you buddy here's a
question here's a question don't touch
me again man I'm asking you not to touch
well sure I'll just pad you nice I know
but I don't want to be fed on know who
you are it's not just gonna he'll beat
me up I didn't say so mad you're not
gonna silence me but there are people
are like you are I mean again lest we
forget that Marco Rubio really cares
more about the NRA endorsement than he
does the students at Parkland or anybody
in the state that's me forget the Marco
Rubio is complicit with everything he
signed off on so many things from Donald
Trump that I can't even say that he's
better let's let's not forget that Marco
Rubio has benefited from Alex Jones just
like every other conservative that being
said I actually did appreciate him
saying no I handed you myself my dude
Amy I am still not I know toxic
masculinity is a horrible Judah it is a
horrible thing and I not be I'm not
joking it really is a disgusting thing
that would cause you to be sick in your
body it's actually very toxic but damn
that was a girl that was like an amazing
interaction and have you ever met
someone who is worthy of how can I say
this and not get in trouble I don't
think I can't say it but I would just
say Alex Jones is probably the most
punchable person in the galaxy I've
never seen someone who was so childish
so disgusting so provocative in the
sense he is seeking to provoke you he's
seeking to provoke violence out of you
I'm not particularly a fan of Jimmy Dore
but I definitely appreciated div Jimmy
Dore doing the lowbrow thing a couple of
years ago when he spent in Alex Jones's
face I'm sorry I know David's not gonna
ever bring me back because you know
generally I have very edgy moderate
takes when I'm on his show but Alex
Jones man who you know that let me stop
now before I never get an invitation
back today's program was made possible
in part by Blink esteem / Pakman I love
bling cast it's the really perfect app
for anybody who likes politics and
learning and if you're watching or
listening to the David Pakman show
I'm sure you love politics and learning
and what Blinky's does is take the best
and most popular non-fiction books they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many books as we would like I know that
I'm at my limit for how much I can read
and this way you can absorb the most
important valuable information from
books in just 15 minutes maybe on your
way to work maybe on your way to the gym
maybe cooking vegan recipes at home
whatever is your thing and our audience
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube i've put a link in
the video description and after the free
trial if you like it and I think you
will you can continue enjoying thousands
of condensed audiobooks for just about
five bucks a month you can go to be li
NK is t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up